[Music]
[Applause]
all right we make the smooth segue to
Booger McFarland football analyst for
the mothership appears on college
football coverage throughout the season
and uh ESPN's Monday Blitz other Studio
shows he was all fired up yest or Sunday
talking about Florida State bring booger
in here um if you were in the committee
room and they were just ready to go out
out and announce who was going to be in
last call what would you have said to
the committee members to make sure that
Florida state was going to be in the
final
four guys I think we have a um a problem
and the problem is this is that we're
making judgment inside this room on what
we think is going to happen on the field
and need I remind you Friday night we
watched Oregon play Washington everyone
that I talked to outside of the state of
Washington thought that Oregon was a
better team than Washington Vegas had
him as a 10-point favor depending on
which book you looked at Washington
won tan was a favorite over
SMU everyone thought that tane would
beat SMU Vegas had him as a favorite SMU
won the game with a second team
quarterback Dan and I think I would have
told everybody let's be
careful this sport has always been a
show me sport you play it on the grass
between the white lines and regardless
of what we think we know how many times
have we been surprised by teams making a
run whether it's pro football or college
football remember the New York Giants 9
and seven wild card team barely got in
remember those
Giants and I think we all know what
happen that season so you never know
what's going to happen and and I think
we better be careful when we start
playing the game inside a nice
comfortable room eating scrambled eggs
and bacon and you know nice little warm
fire there uh because the game is not
played that way and I would have just
put my put my microphone down and told
them all uh if if you can honestly say
that you know that you know that Florida
State can't win a game or two in the
playoff then you can sleep well at night
but I
can't yeah I I it's the cruel reality of
this booger it is a is a beauty pageant
at the end of the season everything that
is window dressing during the season
where are you top four five who's in
who's all of that it comes down to the
bottom line it's going to be fan bases
that travel games that are interesting
will you go to two bowl games will you
fill up the stadiums will people tune in
to watch this there's a lot of ancillary
things that happen here I don't think
the ACC is viewed as a true power
conference I think it's the Big 10 and
in the SEC Pack 12 probably with their
conference schedule this year better
conference than the ACC I think this was
a reality check for the ACC of where
they stand in college football we may
not like it but there's Unwritten rules
you go undefeated you're supposed to
play for a national championship well if
you have your starting quarterback I
certainly understand that and and even
if their backup quarterback booger if
they put up 28 points against Louisville
I think they're in yeah I just think I
think the committee looked at this and
went there's no draw with this team
there's no reason if Jordan Travis plays
then yes but they it's unfair but it's
the reality of this and that's what
people have to understand it's about
money and it's a bottom line business
well Dan I'm going to disagree with you
right there again I think you're doing
the same thing if you're projecting yeah
it's a draw but football is never been
about um I'm not agreeing with it I'm
explaining it Boer right yes I get that
but football is football is a sport man
like we watch football because we never
really know Any Given Sunday that's the
old cliche and so when you start talking
about the draw and the matchup and
what's sexy who cares what's sexy this
is not this is this is not a sport like
figure skating this is not that it's
never been that so even though we want
to make it that out to be a beauty
pageant the innate nature of the game of
football takes you away from being that
and so I hear you and I hear everybody
that's saying man it's about the money
and the matchups and all these different
things yeah to a certain extent you can
schedule those matchups in the
non-conference but when you start
putting together a playoff that is
earned that is something that is earned
and so I will go to my grave saying that
Florida State based on what we do and
and to your point here's what I'll say
to you so 10 of the 10 of the 13 members
on the committee were the same last year
okay there's there's three of are
different last year I think you and I
can both agree Alabama who lost to
Tennesse who lost LSU was a better team
than TCU yes I think they were a better
team yeah TCU lost the conference
Championship to Kansas State they put
TCU in the playoff so why last year did
we not go and get the best team last
year what's the difference to me there
is no difference so I just think based
on the people in that room for whatever
reason and I'm not going to speak for
him they made up in their mind that
Florida State can't compete and there
there are coaches in the room there's
two coaches in the room and I can't
believe those two coaches let that
happen and maybe they were the ones who
were in The Forefront of leading the
charge I have no idea I wasn't in the
room I just think it's a dangerous game
to play sports inside a room instead of
on a court or on the grass I agree I
understand it I just try to explain what
was told to me by uh you know a uh
higher authority involved in college
football do you agree with it I know
it's a TV
show I know that's not what I ask you
Dan do I agree with the the four teams
that are in correct
yes yeah and why is that I I once again
I deal in reality of a bottom line and
that is these These are sexy matchups
Marquee mat Texas might be the best team
you got Harbaugh in there you got Nick
sabbin Alabama I mean uh Washington has
a great quarterback wide rece like we
want to see excitement this if the NFL
could prevent a team from the NFC south
from hosting a playoff don't you think
they would do
that don't you think they could they
can't but college football can create
what they want to create the NFL can't
the NFL would go hey you know who's in
Cowboys and the Chiefs they're in the
Super Bowl hey Atlanta's going to host a
playoff game and may have eight wins on
the season they can't the case then then
if that's the case why are we playing
the games well I I understand what
you're saying I just have to look at
both sides with this do I think Florida
state has an argument absolutely do I
feel bad for that coach that team that
quarterback absolutely but I've been
around for a long time doing this and
understanding what motivates the reason
why we're going to 12 teams is why
booger because of money why did we go
from two to four when they finally
realize how much money they could make
that's why we're going to 12 March
Madness used to be 32 teams it's 68 why
it's
money it's not always
fair and and that's that's where I I end
on its money it's unfortunate but it's
money I get it all right Booger
McFarland joining us on the program if
uh you were a member of the New York
Jets today and Zach Wilson came into the
locker
room as a
veteran what would you say or
do well um I think we all have a job and
this is called pro football like like
we're all men in here and we get paid a
lot of money to do this job and if if
he's been deemed to be the next man up
to come back in and play quarterback I
understand the sensitivity and I
understand the emotion uh that's a very
sensitive position that is a very um
mentally challenging issue they have in
New York but at the end of the day I
would tell them you're a professional if
it's your it's no different in baseball
if it's your turn to grab the ball you
grab the ball and you step on the mound
if it's your turn to get under Center
you go under center now here's what I
would say I would tell the coach if you
want me to go back back under Center
I'll go back under Center but don't pull
me let me play because this yo-yo going
back and forth I can't do that now if
you want me you want me if you don't
then tell me you don't but what I'm not
going to do is I'm not going to subject
myself mentally to going in and out
based on the emotion of it an
organization and a fan base who
ultimately doesn't want me they want
Aaron Rogers and so I understand as a
veteran player what's going on in the
locker room everyone in that locker room
wants a different quarterback the only
reason they want Zach to play is they're
trying to get competent play now until
Aaron can hopefully miraculously come
back from this Achilles so I truly
understand Dan it's like this I'm a
married man I think you are too imagine
if your wife say hey I want you to hang
around another month or two until this
new hot young hot young sexy guy comes
along how the hell would you feel I mean
come on man and so I I I get what Zach
is going through uh but at the end of
the day this is professional football
you get paid a check every Tuesday you
grab the ball and you go play I I get
what you're saying and it's a an
intelligent take on that of let me play
good or bad support me but don't all of
a sudden after you know one half you're
going to bench me and then I have to
regroup and then get ready for the
following you know like Mac Jones like
don't yeah you can't you're you're not
going to get any progress M Jones is
dead in the England like he he's done
right yeah I mean it's just it's amazing
it's amazing though we want and that's
the one position you have to have
confidence of of all of them we're going
to take away your confidence now go get
them but I don't know if maybe he said
that in a way and it's being spun in a
different way like hey I go out there
but support me if not then I don't want
to go out there because now Aaron Rogers
got involved as a mediator here here and
it feels like there's more to it I don't
know if we're making more therefore
that's why it's become a bigger story I
would tend to agree with you without
understanding the entire conversation or
or the entire quote that's being spread
out there about he doesn't want the ball
um I would need to know more generally
speaking uh again we're pro football
players we line up and we go play
they're extenda circumstances in New
York he's been he's he's started he's
been like he's been bent if you go back
to his his entire career he's been
benched what two or three times maybe
even more than that and so you have to
understand the context of what's going
on with this young man uh I've been very
critical of Zack Wilson going going back
when he didn't accept blame for how bad
he played and so I I think the kid has
been through a lot I would just be
careful if I'm New York uh they made the
first Mistake by making him the backup
you didn't want him move on bring
somebody else in and now the situation
becomes less toxic and so hopefully
after this season regardless of what
ever Aaron does if Aaron's going to come
back for another year they get another
backup quarterback let the young man go
on about his business because it's clear
to me they don't want him in New York
they need him but they don't want him in
New York and I don't think the fan base
wants him either I was looking at some
numbers the number of quarterbacks who
have played so far this year I think
it's 70 quarterbacks have thrown a pass
they can't make it any safer can
they I mean what do you want put flags
on I mean you can't touch it listen Dam
the rules are so bad right
now uh Sapp and I were talking about
this if you go and Sack a quarterback
somewhere between hitting the
quarterback and on the way to the ground
you have to figure out a way to levitate
that way you don't land on the
quarterback too hard like come on man
seriously like some of these things are
defying human logic like it it defies
physic how can a 300 pound guy stop his
weight in like a half a second and then
roll over and I'm like come on guys like
you may as well put a flag on him yeah I
I don't well Trevor Lawrence got injured
by his own teammate so it's some of
these injuries are preventable and some
are you know self-induced here so that's
where I don't know what else you can do
other than what we've already done which
is above and beyond the Call of
Duty I was told this years ago and it's
still true it's not if a quarterback or
a player is going to get hurt it's when
we all get hurt yeah if you think about
the great quarterback
and they've all been hurt Brady Manny
Rogers Rivers Matt Ryan I mean just go
down the list all of them have been hurt
at one point or another like this is not
a game where you're gonna stay pain or
injury free you're entire career Patrick
Mahomes had a dislocated knee like
everybody has you get hurt in this game
and so to your point can they make it
any safer no but you can do the you can
do the old pton Manning anytime anybody
gets near just fall down I think that's
the only thing quarterbacks can
do uh good to talk to you keep fighting
the good fight there booger thank
you always enjoy being on with you man
happy holidays to you and the crew man
love this show love talking to you all
the time thank you booger and that's
Booger McFarland of the mothership he
appears on ABC's college football Studio
coverage as well the ESPN Monday Blitz
and other Studio shows